[Captioned via Y Translator]
Today, we're going to look at a fun
and easy way to build yourself
a rocket using PVC pipe,
water, and a soda bottle.
[Music]
To get started, we'll need
a length of 1/2 inch PVC pipe,
four 1/2 inch PVC pipe caps,
three 1/2 inch T's,
and one piece of 1 and 1/4 inch
pipe about 2 inches long.
We'll want a pipe cutter, a saw,
or some way to cut the PVC.
This is what we've got in mind.
We'll build a frame and latch
system out of our PVC pipe,
fill a soda bottle a little bit
with water, and then add pressure.
Once it's where we want it,
we pull a string, and let it fly.
First off, just a quick test,
we want our soda bottle to just
barely fit over the PVC pipe,
and with 1/2 inch PVC,
that's what it should do.
First up, we want to cut off
a piece just over 1 foot long.
I'm going to go
for about 13 inches.
This is the first piece
of our launch set up,
and this is what's going to fit
inside of our soda bottle,
which will be turned into our rocket.
We now need to build a frame,
and it's going to be sort of H-shaped
with this piece coming right
out of the center of the H.
Let's cut two pieces
that are 10 inches long,
and four pieces that are 6 inches long.
[Music]
We want to attach a T on
to the bottom of this first piece.
We'll have two pieces coming
off of either side,
those will each end in a T-shape,
and then we'll have arms coming
off of each of those spots.
With each of those four
arms covered with a cap.
And with that,
we have the basic frame
for our rocket launcher.
It's pretty stable.
It doesn't twist
either direction.
Of course, right now,
it's not held together with anything
but a little bit of friction,
so it does collapse.
We'll be using glue
once we're ready though.
Our soda bottle, which
we're going to fill
with water, wants to fit down
onto this launcher about two-thirds
of the way up the bottle.
Just mark that point.
That's about how far down we want
the neck the bottom of our bottle.
As a launching mechanism,
we're going to be using
a bunch of zip ties.
These things are durable, they're springy,
and they're cheap,
which makes them a great tool.
We want eight of these.
Eight, there's eight.
These are going to be held
in place with a pipe clamp.
We're just going to take that,
and right now, we're
going to drop that down onto our pipe.
We want to be able to take
all eight of these zip ties,
and space them just right evenly
all the way around this pipe.
To do that, let's take
a piece of duct tape,
wrap that all the way around the pipe,
and then mark where it starts
and finishes, so we can line all
of our zip ties up
against the tape.
We're going to leave about 3
and 1/2 inches of our zip tie
above the tape,
and you can see
that on one side
of the zip tie, the head is just flat,
and on the other side, it's a bump.
And we want the bump
to be sticking up towards us,
and the flat side to be
attached to the tape.
[Music]
There we go.
That's much better.
We've got almost a perfectly even
distribution all the way around.
It's going to be off
by a little bit here and there,
and that's not a problem.
We just want to try
and make it as evenly spread as we can.
Let's just trim off the bottom
of all eight zip ties right
below our tape.
[Music]
Now, we need our soda
bottle down in place.
We've already measured that,
and we want these zip ties
to be lined up so they are right
above the widest lip on our bottle.
Not these little bumps that are
the threads putting the cap on,
but this collar around the neck.
We want our zip ties
to fit right above that.
[Music]
With the tape on there,
it actually doesn't really stick too much,
because there's so
many zip ties in the way,
that the tape isn't touching PVC.
But that's alright.
It lets us make sure we've got
our alignment just right.
[Music]
The bottle where we want it.
Check the zip ties.
This is why we want
our hose clamp.
This is going to squeeze down
and really hold all
of those zip tie pieces in place.
There we go.
Now our zip ties
aren't going anywhere.
You can already see
the we can get a pretty
good grip on the bottle.
To get an idea of how
this mechanism is going to work,
our 1 and 1/2 inch piece of PVC pipe,
we can fit right down
over those zip ties,
when we drop our bottle down into place,
and lift this portion
of PVC, it holds all
of the zip ties in place.
They can't move away anymore,
and so now,
they're holding that bottle
right where we wanted,
and even if you add a lot
of pressure pulling it up,
it's not going to go anywhere
until we drop down this collar,
and set it loose.
One more thing we do want to do is
that our bottle does fit pretty
nicely right over the PVC,
but it's not a perfect fit.
And it doesn't need to be 100% perfect,
but we do want a little bit tighter
than it is now.
We're going to use
some electrical tape,
wrap it around this PVC post,
and that will create a seal
that is water and air tight,
or at least, pretty
close that will hold
while we add pressure to our bottle.
This marking where all
of our zip ties reach to right now,
because this step, well,
it may not always be
technically necessary, I think helps.
So I'm just going to loosen
our hose clamp a little bit.
Now that we've seen how
these are going to work,
I can drop them down out of the way.
This line here represents where
our water bottle neck will reach,
and so we're going to start
about halfway over that line.
I'm going to pull
this electrical tape nice and tight.
So it's a very thin barrier.
I'm just going to wrap it
around a few times.
[Music]
I'm taking the bottle,
and I'm pressing it down,
and it's actually just smushing
that electrical tape.
And that's just going to build up
into sort of a ring.
That ring is what's going to hold all
of the water and compressed air back
as we add pressure into our bottle.
Now, we need to take one of our caps
and add a Schrader valve into it.
That's the same kind you
see on a bicycle tire,
and that's how we're going to add
pressure into the whole system.
We've got a 1/2 inch drill bit,
drill a hole right into one of our caps.
[Music]
Schrader valve stuck through,
and now we need to pull it.
There we go,
until it seats self.
There's a groove in the valve,
and that's what we want
to sit right along the edge
of where we drilled the hole.
At this point, we need
to take some PVC glue,
and attach all of our pieces
together permanently, making sure
that we have enough glue,
and they're really well attached,
so that no air will leak out.
That glue does need to dry all the way
before we start doing
any pressure testing on it,
but while it's drying,
I think this is going
to be a good time to add some decoration.
Because we love declaration.
[Music]
Now, we do like decoration
on all parts of the launcher.
However, the top part of this post
really needs to be pretty smooth
so that our bottle will launch off
into the way we want,
and we don't really
want to get paint all
over all the moving parts,
the zip tie pieces that
are gonna be holding stuff together.
So this top post will just
be the color it is.
We've also taped off the Schrader valve,
because we don't want to get
that plugged up.
The rest of it though,
let's make it a little more interesting.
[Music]
Now that everything is decorated,
we can move on to adding a little bit
of a spring system.
Now, this pipe is what's going
to hold all of these zip ties closed,
but it you know, it's...
Gravity is currently
pointing down.
We want it to stay up so that it
holds our bottle locked in place
until we pull down on it.
So to make that spring,
we're just going to use
a couple more zip ties.
We're going to attach them
around this tube,
and around this T joint,
and that should give us the spring that
we need to hold it in place.
I think it's time for a quick test
with no water in our bottle,
and very low pressure.
This is just to see how
everything is working out so far.
It is still really
low pressure though.
It hasn't even hit like 10 psi.
[Music]
Tiny delay in taking off,
but that hit my hand
with some good power.
So this is working out nicely.
We've got this all painted up,
and we need to be able to pull this down
from a little bit of a distance,
so that we're not just
like always getting soaked
every time we launch this.
Plus it's hard to watch it
for right here firing.
So we need to attach some cord on here,
and make it so we can pull from the side,
and have it drop this down.
So we're going to over engineer
this just a little bit.
We're going to attach two
of these eye hooks down into the PVC,
and they're going to be drilled,
and then thread it in,
and we're going to add
some epoxy just to make sure
that we keep our air tight seal
through all the pipes.
Then we're going to have cord attached
to the side of the PVC coming down
through the eye hooks,
and connecting in the front.
So when we pull forward,
it will pull down
on our trigger mechanism.
Our launcher is now built.
It should be complete and working well,
so what we need now is to turn our bottle
into a rocket,
and there's lots
of different ways we can do that.
Today, we're just going to use
a little bit of craft foam
and duct tape to add
a cone on the front,
and some fins on the sides.
[Music]
I'd say that works
and it's time to start
filling this with water.
Take it somewhere like a field,
instead of you know, inside.
See what it can do.
We've got our launcher,
we've got our rocket,
and I'm just going to use some
of these little garden stakes to make sure
that it holds the launcher down,
and I can already pull on this
and trigger it pretty well.
But you know, if I pull too hard,
I don't want it to tip,
and then shoot the rocket off,
whatever weird angle.
We now want to fill our rocket
partially with water,
and I say partially
because it kind of ends up
being a little bit different every time.
Sometimes you want about 1/3 full,
sometimes 1/2 full,
and we'll have to do
some experimentation to figure out.
All right.
I'm just going to try
and pop this on as quick
as I can to avoid spilling
too much water down the tube.
[Music]
That worked all right.
Now, there may even be a little bit
of leaking down at the seal,
and more once I
start adding pressure,
but it's going to be minut.
It won't be severe,
and it should still
work pretty well, even though it's gonna--
I don't think it's leaking at the moment,
but it probably will
once I start adding pressure.
Just little bits trying
to escape out that seal
between the water bottle
and the tape around the PVC pipe.
All right, let's add some pressure,
and see how this goes.
Oh!
Oh, I think it it popped off
our lock a little bit.
When I say a little bit,
I mean completely, because obviously,
it just popped right off.
It may be that we just need
to add two more zip ties
on the sides to give
some extra push up on this.
All right, we've got more
zip ties adding pressure.
Let's see if that actually increases
how much we can put in.
3, 2, 1.
More pressure.
[Music]
Random Fact: The fastest rocket record
was set by the ATLAS V in 2006,
which reached a top speed
of 47,000 miles per hour
or about 76,000 kilometers per hour.
There might be a little bit
of water in the system.
3, 2, 1
Oh, almost had it.
So I think so far,
we've had a lot of good launches.
Our best ones, probably went
about a hundred feet up,
which is not bad for a soda bottle
and some PVC powered by a bike pump.
We do have one more thing
we want to try with this,
and that's just see what happens
if we use a little bit
more luminescent fluid than water.
All right guys,
now it's night time,
and we have two jars full of the two
different components of glow fluid.
One of which is slightly going already
because of a an inadvertent break
in the glass as I was emptying them out.
However, we'll add some fuel,
and we'll see if we can get this
to launch with glowing fuel,
the color of like rocket fire
flying out of the back of this.
I hope it works out.
We kind of only have
one shot because...
Do you know how many glow sticks you
have to get for this much liquid?
This is like 60 glow sticks right here,
and they're big glow sticks too.
Maybe more, it might be
as much as a hundred.
I wasn't counting to carefully.
But there's a lot.
And so yeah, we get
about one shot of this.
I got super fancy high
quality funnel that I made
out of duct tape.
[Music]
All right, I'm gonna add soap,
swirl it around,
and then load it up.
[Music]
Ultra bright.
All right.
Starting to leak.
3, 2, 1.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Oh that poor bike pump.
That poor everything.
Well, there's our-- Our spent rocket.
Little residual glow fluid
coming out there.
I mean, Rocket Fuel
That look great.
We got a couple
of cool swirl patterns here.
I think maybe it's spun is
it went out or something?
I'm not really sure,
but we've got like a swirl arm that
that reaches around that way,
and then another one
coming out this direction,
and you can just
see the whole spray pattern everywhere.
The whole project is quick.
It's cheap.
It goes together easily.
This is a great thing to do
with young kids, because it's just
water spraying out of a bottle.
Gonna be a lot of fun.
Guys, thanks for watching.
But that's not all,
we've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top
will transport you
directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you aren't a subscriber,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you never miss out
on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.